als nächster checkpoint wunderbar gut
aber es geht macht es wahrscheinlich so
liebe leute da sind wir in der
allerletzten folge ein npd zu dem
adventure gleich zudem mit wir haben
noch zwei maps vor uns die seht ihr hier
links und rechts nahmen scanning clips
die letzte map und davor kommt im
bibelgarten und es gibt eigentlich sind
die es zu holen und wir gehen rein wie
unser wie unser ach so dann diese
forderung ja hier gibt es drei hütten
und vier normale oral-b wie einfach
edewechter sportpistole verfechter an
land versteckt
hier geht's schon los die ich hab zwei
kisten gefunden als ob mit eis aber mit
eis cola bankengruppe überwachung an den
start gehen wir mal kurz denn ich glaube
ich keine keine extra tests welche
richtung hier ist es hier ist die 13 31
dollar labyrinth omnicom hermia auf
damit ich bin so stolz auf mich der
kurzen check point a eröffnet wenn wir
es brauchen
das habe ich dann gemacht weiter
eigentlich alles klar
wo läuft gut für mich ich bin einfach
total total die stride ich weiß nicht wo
ich lange letzter sprung letzter sprung
was ist denn das hier das ist doch
vorgarten war ja ich mache selbst check
also wenn ihr jetzt hier checkpoints
post ich habe angst aber ich darf die
kann ja selbst setzen das spiel
irgendwann wie soll das denn gehen
musste
abspringen man nicht setzen
als ob man sich täglich den sprung auf
dem weg zur arbeit als ob immer dafür
dass man blöcke platzieren
ich war halt einfach gemacht nein keine
platzieren also bis zum helfen benutzen
dann joussen wir die halt nie benutzt
haben um zu stecken oder so wichtig
schafft den sprung einfach als ob ich
jetzt an diesem sprung über das ist doch
dass es unmöglich ist die luft besser
hatte den vorteil dass musik kuchen her
ich habe den sprung nicht ich auch nur
noch ein diamant gefunden aber nicht
dazu ob ich noch alle 16 diamanten
kommen am ende noch alles februar im
shop spams dann schlafe ich nicht wie
machst du denn was ja spät ab sprich
ganz ganz ganz spät abschwung als west
und vier blocks sprung
ok ich mal was laut stadt etwas damals
front an diesem platz
ja du kannst eigentlich nicht nicht
sterben oder so
das ist echte blamage schafft ihn nicht
ich bin so den übelsten und wenn's um
diesen sprung geht
hey ich hasse die sprünge auch diesen so
unfassbar benutzen und einmal hin
abzukürzen ja ist zudem kommen mach mal
na ja sagt tom der baklava zu viele zu
viele parcours
ich mag die aber das mache ich ganz gern
ich sag mal eine bring ich darüber
wollen nämlich den rollen
sie wollen die rolle neuer fonds ich
raste aus
manuel neuer ich glaub es nicht ich
hab's geschafft weil ein neuer oder wir
haben ja ich habe alle drei ich auf alle
drei diamanten schon mal gefalle 3
hinten alter und ist damit seien hätten
parcours
das ist echt schlimm ich finde aber ich
krieg hat gar nichts auf die reihe
also was labyrinthe angeht nein ich hab
ich hab gerade jetzt die letzte kiste
entdeckt
bei der bis jetzt komplett mit dem
parcours durch oder musst du hast nur
die drei hätten jetzt gefragt okay nur
die hin denn er ist wie zb darf ich sie
bitten so was jetzt habe ich die vier
normale dinge von nahem marc rass 21
logo ein so junger und 20er ältesten
das ist hier das nächste level
entscheidet würde ich jetzt am 19
ich bin hier gerade total am verwirrt
sein weil diese blätter bei mir gar
nicht klar dass auch gern schon aufhören
also günstig schon durchschnitt also
wäre ich ja und man diese sportart
entscheiden vorteil gegeben hat zu lange
sprang dann für mich ein bisschen
meister wahrscheinlich ich kann einfach
da habe ich meine form hält auch ihren
gesetzt worden sich zu nah oder so
perfekt busty heart
ich glaube das wird eher was für logo
sein ich nehme ich nehme den das buch
aus es gibt 3 hinten und vier am ende
des parcours
ok also wer gewinnt es unentschieden
zumindest schon mal und dann kommt es
auf die hätten also an eclipse chemex
labs alaska okay dann ist aber ich hab
im gartenhaus probleme das mal kurz
überlegen sollen wir nicht da oben
starten einfach machen dann setze ich
hier auch mainz powerpoint ja ich auch
einmal hohe alter unmöglich oder da kann
ich mag es eigentlich ganz cool
das hätten wir schon die ganze zeit
machen sondern ich immer diese seltsame
checkpoints laufen
ich wollte einfach da wohin sprung nicht
entsprechen fröhlich wegen dir nach und
ich spiele einfach nein ja noch nie egal
wie es jetzt kommen wenn sebastian alle
diamanten auf dieser web findet habe ich
trotzdem aber jetzt aber jetzt nicht
mehr sport nicht mehr spontan setzen ab
jetzt im leben
aber jetzt gute lauf beim elektrisch
grad
ja ich lass dich um du n joy the jump
einfach ultra lexikon kann mehr ich
beeinflusse dich gerade nach dem
jubiläums wurde von dem komplex die
rache und hatten virus installiert bei
long hat einfach mal sagen hier erstmal
schön india geholt hier von der
seitenkästen der locker hättest du hast
mich die ganzen hype sprüche aus mir
raus ok stille kehrte ein gut alle sind
direkt und konzentrierte vorne
gearbeitet werden so konzentrierte vorne
wenn jetzt fällt alles von vorne oder
wat maybe gar nicht du kannst hier
wieder an wie du musst wieder von vorne
alles machen
hey wie gehts ja auch darüber achso
darunter war keine wahl kein check point
sagt doch da ist mir checkpoint nein
nein du musst du hier weiter spitze
nicht auf den auf den daten und dann
durch das holz
da schaut man mich bittet der republik
der letzte von mir glauben hellsten
sprung nach vorne gefehlt da wo du glaub
ich bis auch bei diesem einen in dem
haus und gewicht jetzt einfach hier gar
nicht schaffen
selbst die leiter nicht hingekriegt was
machst du schon mal dem chip was ich
wirklich schafft den sprung nicht ich
war schon lacht ja ich habe aber auch
gar nichts mehr geht ja überhaupt weil
schon wieder sind dachte scheiße hatte
ich gar nicht mehr da ist es ja besser
wenn er die ganze map von vorne was
bisher schneller als wenn ihr den hier
machst ich krieg den können wir das mal
bitte da ist das möglich ist es jetzt
geschafft
du musst nicht überspringen weil ich bin
noch hinter dir deswegen habe die chance
sich auch zu holen naja du kannst du
kannst erst kennen wenn du wenn ich das
auch geschafft hat würde ich sagen ja
das ist weil wir jetzt weitermachen
seltsam also hier ich schaffe diese
weise das ging ja schon weil der letzte
mal irgendwie nicht das nicht geteilt
bekomme diesen einen sprung noch nicht
und ich bin jetzt auch da so erleichtert
guck mal guck mal probleme du kriegst
diese springer hin ich schaffe die nach
ihrem neuesten schon am nächsten tag
konnten wird einfach drüber gesamt wie
die letzte eidechse
das sind meine freunde der checkpoint
freudig ich fühle mich da ganz ruhig im
block in machen aber ich schaffe inhalt
so ziemlich easy macht aber keinen sinn
so liegt mir nicht
du bist du es bist ja auch ein
checkpoint also der sollte einem nicht
zum verhängnis werden
ja wenn ich dann aber den leiter sprung
nicht schaffe dann weiß kann aber sein
dass das eisenharten soll ich einfach
schmidt warum chocolat mit
warum springt muss jetzt alles noch mal
machen dass da hinten jetzt ein
checkpoint ich habe einen trick konnte
das gibt es nicht meine kakteen
enttäuschen mich aber aber sebastian
wohl richtig dass ich bin ich bin auf
deiner seite
natürlich dass auch im dong dong hinter
mir aber ich würde versuchen
ach komm schon du hast nicht geschafft
meine ist gut dass ich habe glück im
blick ich stelle mich ein bisschen ein
bisschen blöd die blöde an gerade com
jetzt die pusht dich bestimmt
ok jetzt ganz konzentriert hier bin ich
vorn gescheitert okay das ist keine
balken über mir alter wie ich diesen
leitern sprung hätte mich schaffen aber
immer hängen über dem schweizer stand
immer an der wand
okay hier ist der jackpot schon geöffnet
hat
ich habe den nächsten checkpoint oben
fast nicht aktiviert
welcher seite die leiter ist für den
checkpoint hinterm haus system
ok dann kann ich hab jetzt echt 0
gesehen einen drink an den kunden zurück
hier noch zum abschluss den grünen
abschluss
ja ich setze hier sind eisbären berlin
ab beamten checkpoint ne ne scheiße wie
sowie was denn was im firmenblog was
muss was da ist schon wieder so ein
check point wo man einen sprung machen
muss denn ich nicht schaffe also hier
sein
als nächster jackpot wunderbar gut aber
es gemacht dass wahrscheinlich ja es
kann heute im pokal hitze bitte danke
bitte bitte bitte liebe und sitze was
erlauben strunz ich bin gerade
verzweifelt ich verzweifelt am tag
kommen
das ist ja so asozial ist jetzt die in
kakteen vier blocks sprung oder wie ist
das möglich 90 1 noch mal hätte wenn du
abspringt motto ernst da kann man gar
nicht statt anlaufen wie asozial das ist
ein gerät das sie alle sind so asozial
das ist die asoziale wüste schlechthin
ich welche übel da war da war doch ein
geschenk sein wo ist bewusst dass oben
oder war ja hier habe ich diesen blog
schaffen
ach so günstig ist daher komme ich nicht
hin an die leiter
zwar versucht gerade ja gut der eisblock
der natürlich kann man jetzt noch nicht
runterfallen
ich hab' ich habe irgendein problem wenn
ich verfolgt werde
dann kann ich nicht spielen ganz in ruhe
spielen ich bin noch zu fünf checkpoints
hinterher
ich bin hinter ihr fahrender kollege ich
bin mit ihr jetzt die welche richtung
rhön hier springen jetzt links oder
rechts benutzer profis beim erstmalig
den auf anhieb geschafft aber jetzt habe
ich im blog hat und er scheint mir
unmöglich will ich was für ein sprung
ist
dass ich hier lang der ist in der tat
asien nein leuten ein was diese ist
nicht zu fassen wie kann man so ein
sprungbrett bauer a
von dem kaktus auf das eis springen nein
warum
und dann nicht das ist doof alter ich
hab jetzt 55 minuten drauf sind neben
alte logo klau s ens magix.net folgte
kommst du nicht hin wenn das jetzt nicht
die acht kommen dann kürzen jetzt die
ganze strecke ab
ich traf sie ja da kann man jetzt hinten
einsteigen aber gleich wurde dann von
hans passmann die rocker da kann's jetzt
einsteigen
einsteigen bitte einsteigen außerdem
noch ab
ich hab schon wieder verpackt also das
wasser ist jetzt schon nicht gerade ich
mal kurz in seinem blog
ach du scheiße schilderte so diese
kakteen sprünge rasieren mein leben das
ist so schlimm
erstens gegen das vielleicht aber hier
geht es kann mehr 26 bis 26 ja gibt ihm
einen versteckten mann
ich habe einen versteckten gefunden ja
ich habe auch einen gibt es jetzt noch
ein aber nicht ernst wird denn jetzt für
meno ja ich habe einen eigentlich habe
ich ja ein weg gegeben eigentlich hätte
ich sag mal so wie jetzt fünf minuten
vorsprung bekommen müssen weil ich die
ganze zeit an die kakteen spanner
gehangen habe ja im prinzip ist das war
aber logo auf deinem blog weg gemacht
aber wir sind einfach alle gewinner
leute komme ich jetzt mal richtig und
wichtig da wir teilen die diamonds durch
drei andern ist alles schön jetzt
klappen wir uns nochmal kommen
lediglich anja kling sowieso erst
das war eine springe hier ich ausraste
meine stadt urologie der nächste kam kam
kam es der nächste hier beim spam spams
das logo kommt aber den lassen wir außen
abgelassen
das ist okay erzählt rektor nicht ohne
dich hab ich mich einmischen
natürlich nur abnicken wollte ich aber
kein tier hat ja ob er in dieser anreiz
bot apple oder uncharted golden abyss
weiß ich nicht also ich kann ich mir
klicken gerade einfach mal sagen du bist
gar nicht so gut wie du immer sagt so
das war's eigentlich ne nachdachte habt
ihr denn die aschen rausgenommen haben
wir noch eine kiste und
schreibt einen kommentar oder mit einer
bewertung wie er das noch weitermachen
sollen eventuell ansonsten war's das
jetzt für immer mit geld oder wurde
vielleicht noch mehr sehen eine season
two von gateway vielleicht auch eine
ganz andere map zum beispiel in der
sonne wie heißt die anderen adventure
webseiten die adventure noch zum
beispiel ja ja ja wenn das vielleicht
schreibe es in die kommentare
wenn er bock drauf hat intention eure
möglichkeiten und check die anderen in
der beschreibung ab dann ist es wohl
jetzt das ende das was in allen den
logischen daumen nach oben lassen das
ist lukas ist nicht das ende aller tage
ich komm wieder keine frage